pour les jeunes vous êtes le pot action
j'apprécie énormément parce que ce matin
j'avais des doutes on n'a plus d'excusés
mais une école j'ai pas l'étude
c'est très très très bien habituellement
très discret louis élève en deuxième
année de ces ape cms comprenez employés
de commerce multispécialités du lycée
professionnel jacques prévert de
versailles se mobilisent et dépasse son
handicap pour la collecte nationale des
restos du coeur
ça nous apporte connaissances sur les
restos du coeur ce que l'on pense c'est
que c'est une bonne action qu'on fait
avec notre classe pour aider il faut
aider les gens qui sont dans la misère
après avoir effectué une collecte au
sein de leur établissement les élèves
prêtent main-forte aux bénévoles des
restos du coeur de saint cyr l'école ils
collectent trient et arrange les denrées
offertes par les clients du supermarché
moi ça rapporte le devoir de la relève
lorsque les jambes donné derrière parce
que nous on n'est pas interdit non plus
d'en prévoir secours y aura après on ne
sait pas les voir un peu aussi la
réaction des gens vis-à-vis des jeunes
une mission utile pour les restos du
coeur tout comme pour les élèves qui
expérimente sur le terrain leur
formation théorique on a dans cette
formation des compétences à travailler
sur la vente notamment la réception des
produits également savoir connaître les
différents types de produits qui
existent et donc travailler sur ce
projet c'est là vous permettent de
travailler sur ses compétences là
autrement ça c'est le premier axe et
surtout travaillé sur la socialisation
sur le travail de groupe parce qu'à être
capable de prendre des responsabilités
aussi la mission pour les élèves se
termine vendredi soir mais l'opération
collecte nationale des restos du coeur
se poursuit quant à elle partout en
france jusqu'à dimanche soir